be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so the first
video on mutants who exists beyond
omega-level seem pretty popular and so
what I want to do here is take another
shot at this and talk about a mutant
who's one half of the most common
Franklin Richards debates among Marvel
Comics fans in this video I want to have
a discussion about Mad Jim Jasper's as
well as lay the question to rest which
one is stronger Jim Jasper's or Franklin
Richards
so Matt Jim Jasper's and the crooked
world actually comes out of Marvel's
attempts to branch into the British
audience with a line of comics titled
Marvel UK sitting on Captain Britain a
man named Brian Braddock and the brother
of Psylocke both of whom had lost their
parents at a young age as he was
depicted in his initial appearance
titled Captain Britain weekly in 1976
ryan braddock was a college student
working at a research facility called
dark more energy Research Center which
was attacked by a group called the
reverse led by a man named straggly in
the scene in order to attain help for
the scientists during his escape
Brian fell into the siege perilous which
worked as a dimensional doorway of sorts
coming into contact with a man named
Merlin and his daughter Roma but were
not initially told who they are they
offer Brian Braddock the choice of
choosing between the sword of might or
the amulet of right with dragon the
Reavers having followed him in order to
close out any loose ends
Brian chooses the amulet and is endowed
with the power of flight force fields
super strength and energy projection on
a minor level which allow him to go on
to defeat Strang well as the rest of the
Reavers now in terms of merlin and roma
these to operate is part of the Marvel
multiverse because these early stories
saw Marvel fleshing out the concept of
the multiverse while stories like Days
of Future past would feature alternate
realities under Allen Davis Alan Moore
and David Thorpe Marvel UK was actually
the first line to provide an expansion
to the multiverse in Marvel Comics all
of which was introduced during the
crooked worlds story as they were to
pick it Merlin and Roma existed outside
of the multiverse and served to ensure
its continued existence by destroying
foes that were deemed a danger to the
multiverse itself now where their
purpose seems to run in direct
contradiction with the Living Tribunal
in truth I don't know the answer to this
problem the issue here is that Marvel
never really reconciles the role of
Merlin in relation to the Living
Tribunal except to say that both
individuals simply serve as guardians of
the multiverse
so picking up with Captain Britain along
with a sidekick jackdaw an elf that had
the power to teleport as well as
influence the mind of others the story
saw the two thrown into an alternate
reality called earth 238 by Merlin but
for unknown reasons during their initial
foray into this reality the two had come
upon a group called the crazy gang in
the midst of a robbery and while Captain
Britain and jackdaw are easily able to
overpower the game they end up coming
face to face with Mad Jim Jasper's now
initially Jim Jasper's does not provide
any display of his powers instead he's
largely depicted as the mastermind
behind the crazy gang and their slew of
robberies across Britain however the
world around Captain Britain also seems
extremely strange and that the citizens
and the crazy gang all seem to be
depicted in a manner similar to the
story of Alice in Wonderland in terms of
the various creatures and the physical
appearances of people this becomes
especially apparent when Jim Jasper's
asked his Queen what should happen to
Captain Britain to which she replies
that their head should be cut off and so
taking the fight to the street captain
britain and jackdaw began battling the
forces of Jim Jasper's at which point
they simply reach freed back to the
helicopter in the shape of a teapot
which is being piloted by a dormouse now
at the same time that this is happening
a woman named saturnine leads a group
called the dimensional development cord
and stands as the omniversal magistrates
in her role she oversees the evolution
of realities and ensures that no one
reality falls behind because 2:38 is
considered primitive and that as people
are selfish the politicians are corrupt
and individuals with superpowers don't
seem to exist and because the
progression of all other realities
hinges on the fact that they all
progress equally the goal of saturnine
is to instigate something called the
push which would adjust the minds of
this world's occupants bring them into a
new age of enlightenment in addition to
activating superpowers among its various
citizenry however the powers of Jim
Jasper's come into fruition moments
after the push is initialized when he
starts warping reality now one thing to
keep in mind here is that the
dimensional development court and
saturnine did not
know what was going on with Jim Jasper's
and did not know why all the individuals
the superheroes and everyone had been
wiped out from this reality but getting
back to our story
physically bending the world around him
and driving its occupants insane the
initial reaction of Captain Britain is
that saturnians push has somehow
disrupted the fabric of reality and is
destroying this universe furthermore
while Captain Britain deals with the
fallout
he also encounters a being called the
fury while we're not initially told how
it came to be the police of this world
seem to control it in state that the
fury exists to wipe out superheroes
sending it against Captain Britain the
fury is able to easily overpower Brian
Braddock by analysing the nature of his
powers and adapting to them immediately
unable to cope with the situation and
the fact that the world is seemingly
falling apart of the seams saturnine
gathers her personal guard and bails out
leaving Captain Britain and earth 238 to
its fate killing jackdaw and turning on
Captain Britain the fury begins a
relentless assault that would seemingly
kill Brian until Mad Jim Jasper's
arrives in his teapot helicopter and
rescues Captain Britain however rather
than finding himself in a safe place
Brian Braddock falls further down the
rabbit hole when he enters the
helicopter to find that his interior
violates all laws of physics and that
the inside of the helicopter is larger
than the helicopter itself furthermore
Jim Jasper's provides us with an
explanation of what it was that happened
to this world as well as what's
happening now as he explained at some
point along the line he came to the
realization that he could work reality
and in the process ran for the position
of prime minister on the platform of
being anti superhero now Wyatt was if
you didn't simply will superheroes out
of existence and make himself Prime
Minister is never explained but once he
was elected to the position because his
propaganda had turned Britain against
superheroes he then created the fury
which was designed to kill all the
super-powered people in the world except
for Jim Jasper's himself by virtue of
its programming all of which was done to
ensure that Jim Jasper's was the only
superhero in existence following this
conversation Brian wada comes to the
realization that the room has expanded
in size since the start of their
conversation and that various people now
accompany the two one of which includes
the recently deceased
dog unable to cope with the situation
and losing his grip on reality captain
britain jumps out of the helicopter and
lands at a graveyard dedicated to
various superheroes from britain
including the wildly powerful miracle
man after being tracked down by the fury
the battle between the two is
short-lived as captain britain seems to
give up lashes out at merlin for sending
him to this desolate reality after which
he's completely annihilated by the fury
and so picking up with Merlin and rola
this story transitions to their actions
after acquiring what was left of Captain
Britain on earth 2:38 using their
technology that you were able to
completely rebuild Captain Britain's
physical body as well as restore his
memories and his mind arriving back on
earth-616 from the mind of Captain
Britain his experience was simply that
he arrived on an alternate reality was
killed by the fury and woke up on
earth-616 with no knowledge of the
actions of Merlin or Roma instead
shortly after his arrival a group called
the special executive which served as a
multi-dimensional Valley Hunter group
which had been tasked by the dimensional
development court to reach free Brian
mattock meets with him now as we're told
following the events of Earth 2:38
because the push coincided with Mad Jim
Jasper's warping that reality the belief
of the dimensional development court is
that saturnine had made a mistake
something which was compounded on after
she had simply fled stripping her of her
title of magistrates and holding her
prisoner Captain Britain was summoned in
order to stand at her trial and offer
testimony regarding what had taken place
introducing numerical designations for
the first time in Marvel Comics Marvel
establishes a Captain Britain is only
one member of the Captain Britain Corps
a multi-dimensional group that
safeguards their own realities from
various threats with a Captain Britain
of earth 238 fleeing that reality when
the fury first began killing superheroes
in addition to this because the Jaspers
warp has effectively left the entire
earth 238 continuity in shambles
Saturday's replacement a being named man
dragon eliminates the earth 238 reality
entirely which destroys that version of
mad Jim Jasper's along with everyone in
it however as we discover in the
earth-616 continuity is another version
of Jim Jasper's who like his 238
counterpart is implementing a campaign
to wipe out all of the superhumans in
the world including the Hulk spider-man
and others
furthermore because the fury has the
power to adapt to anything it was
somehow able to adapt to the destruction
of earth 2:38 and because Captain
Britain was transported to the earth-616
continuity the fury developed the
ability to teleport inter-dimensionally
now we don't actually get an explanation
of how this happened I would surmise
that this was most likely for the sake
of the story rather than anything else
but regardless taking the fight directly
to Jim Jasper's himself rather than
falling into something that he doesn't
understand the conflict in the earth 238
universe Captain Britain travels to the
office of the prime minister in London
where madam Jasper's resides but once he
enters the room he finds the massive
form of Jim Jasper's in a space that is
impossibly large indicating that this
version of Jim Jasper's is far more
powerful than his earth 238 counterpart
now what happens next is probably one of
the most insane displays of reality
warping that I've ever seen in a comic
and is one of the reasons why I love Jim
Jasper's character so much
initially Captain Britain is led to
believe that all of this is a dream when
he seems to wake up and is met with
saturnine and jackdaw who try to
convince brian Braddock that none of
this had happened however he suddenly
jolts awake in a hospital bed with a
sister psylocke at his side after
seeming to have come out of a coma with
the doctors arriving and celebrating the
fact that he's awake Captain Britain
goes on to explain his dream only to
learn that all of this was an example of
Jim Jasper's using his powers to warp
reality and so what this does is
essentially point to the fact that in
truth captain Britain is woefully
outmatched against a being of such
incredible power but also confirms that
where Jim Jasper's in the earth 238
universe was still learning to control
his powers the version of earth-616 has
total control over what he can achieve
and so becoming fed up with his battle
with Captain Britain as well as a slow
going process of eliminating superheroes
mad Jim Jasper's simply wipes all of
reality clean and begins with the task
of starting the earth-616 universe all
over again
however after recreating the crazy gang
the group is suddenly met with the
arrival of the fury because the cyborg
hails from the earth 2:38 reality and
can adapt to anything
Jim Jasper's is intrigued due to the
fact of the fury was not affected when
Jim Jasper's wiped everything out
approaching the fury the cyborg realizes
that while it was programmed not to kill
Jim Jasper's in the earth 2:38
continuity this version is a different
Jim Jasper's and that his programming
does not apply attacking Jasper's by
disintegrating his body that you begin
to engage in a literal battle that sees
Jasper's reshaping reality around them
into forms that boggle the mind but with
the fury adapting to every single attack
eventually however the Fury comes to
realise a crucial fact in the realm of
the earth-616 universe or any universe
for that matter
Jasper's is king and can control
anything and everything however there is
one place where Jasper's is completely
powerless and that place is the earth
2:38 continuity because that reality was
destroyed and exists as a void in space
and time the fury realizes that without
a reality to manipulate Jasper's is
powerless now to sidetrack here for a
second as far as the comics have
depicted this is the single difference
that separates Franklin Richards and mad
Jim's a Spurs where Franklin Richards
can create the clay needed to mould
something Jim Jasper's needs the clay to
mould meaning that Jim Jasper's cannot
create something out of nothing while
Franklin Richards can which makes
Franklin Richards a far more powerful
character and so without a reality to
manipulate the fury is able to overpower
Jim Jasper's and by virtue of this able
to destroy his brain entirely killing
him in the process with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I hope you guys enjoyed this
discussion on that Jim Jasper's it was a
long time coming and I will catch you
guys later peace